let's start out tell me what this first
one is the India is just a nice straight
problem
when is the problem above the axis how
did use a particular solution yet
presents go to the graph
tymberlee edges X is negative one
yep and when X is three and more like
what we talked about it Sobotka because
you can't ever see what number that's
both of them at the same time so this or
this doing that so it's going to put
march around man what did you get this
one you got no you you got the same
thing
didn't you because look at the part of
the graph I sort of dodged over here
you said look at the ground here's the
parts that are above and ball right then
when you look at this guy here's the
times that are above and then to the
right of two yeah and do I need to have
a look at the third one the answer is
it's exactly the same
is it more plus X is less than negative
1 or X is greater than 2 now this is
perplexing to me
this is deflecting to it because these
three grads are all very different to
one another how is it that they all have
the same odds are when I posed such
different questions I look back at the
original functions they always very
different they come out looking very
different and what is it that they have
in common
how would you articulate the kids age
have infinitely okay this is exactly the
right word in have we've gone to it in
one okay and this is what it is right
what you have a look at the fact that
here and here here and here here and
here
do you know this did you do is right of
the meaning but that is I pulled out
identical but I can combine them in a
variety of ways to get different graphs
okay however no matter which way I can
buy them when I consider the side of
each one
when the positive when the need
obviously if I ask the negative question
you just get the opposite I mean okay
you get the same result okay so
underneath where you've drawn these raps
I need a bottle subspace so give me a
second would you make a subheading all
right let me give you to the social
we've sort of trade that explains this
subheading is enough for the
intermediate I'd in between the
intermediate value theorem you basically
what I rub observation
so underneath your heading wrong color
what is it talking about this theorem is
about changes in size about where a
function can go positive or go negative
let me stick this in for you and then I
will try and work out for us together
how it actually applies this and how to
transfer okay
the intermediate value theorem states a
function only changes sign at now I'm
going to introduce absorbs zeroes or
discontinuities even though it might be
unfamiliar to you the names are sensible
that you can kind of work out what they
mean let's have a look at
discontinuities these two functions here
have discontinuities what does it mean
for something to be continuous you say
something is a continuum or something
that means it goes from start and an era
nerve breaks I guess there's nothing to
closet in between those breaks are
discontinuous where discontinuous H is a
function if these political asymptotes
right vertical asymptotes are back
discontinuities can you see that these
functions a change sign they go from
positive to negative on either side of
this continuity to notice that looking
is the discontinuity on this side here
your negative and on this I hear your
positive and vice versa for this one
does that make sense that's one of the
places where a function can change signs
well these days
they're not heroes so you so far be
pulling these Bruce Bruce written is a
very general word we tend to only use it
we try to oh these it when we talk about
polynomials so the parabola if you value
x squared plus other stuff a cubic X
cubed plus other stuff or X / 4x plus 5
those things have roots where the
function is equal to zero we also we
call these when we have a look at these
guys we call them activist of sewers
but more generally speaking in function
notation we call them zeros so you need
to use the theory that word and being
asked can you find the zeros of a
function that's where it is been collide
with the x axis
okay do you see why and this is where
the intermediate intermediate value
theorem is named from do you see why if
you want to change sign from negative to
positive or positive Xavier you have to
pass through a sewer
if you don't plus two it is continuing
can you see why it didn't break right
say to go from on in to negative at some
point over here there's gonna be
something like zero point eight that
this is there okay and as you get close
on to changing the sign you get zero
point five and zero point two and so on
if you actually want to break through
the axis and get to something negative
negative zero other maybe one or
something like that do you see you have
the posture zero along the way right
which is why what does this word mean
intermediate when you see this word what
context is in video you seriously need
to be in a intermediary or intermediate
terms like levels of like a horse we
used to call the mass horses standard
intermediate and advanced and you know
even like shirt sizes and through
science
me it just means in between right so you
have this small medium and large medium
just means beside this between small and
light orally so it called the
intermediate value theorem because
intermediate between changes sign it
must be a zero but there is another way
of doing it which is if you break the
function put an asymptote error or
something like that you can change side
on either side so how does the cut for
this underneath this is not hardly on
that you're officially but it what
accounts for this okay a function has
zeros or discontinuities a function has
zeros or discontinuities and using point
B the displace what we look at here what
is a really important powerful IQ to
graphing when is in fact it that's what
may be identified for us as the common
thing between all these functions when
if you factors have zeros okay go back
repeat write x equals negative what do
we say x equals negative 1 and x equals
2 that's it all of the action was
happening that's where all of these had
data future points okay
that's because they were the factors
right and that's where the fact is handy
words that we will have 0 negative 1 and
this side will have a 0 at 2 and that's
why all the activity happens in